the NRA was one of president Trump's
earlier supporters pouring nearly 30
million dollars into his successful
campaign a fact brought up repeatedly by
the organization's leader we stood
proudly with Donald Trump because we saw
through the media deception and
recognized him for who he was the most
openly pro-second amendment presidential
candidate in history the right to bear
arms outlined in the second amendment is
regarded by the NRA as absolute but the
gun control campaign has been fueled by
the sharp increase in the number of mass
killings this year following
back-to-back shootings in Texas
President Trump made a controversial
trip to El Paso that critics contended
was as much a political campaign as
commiseration for the first time though
the president raised the possibility of
stronger background checks on gun buyers
but we have to have this apparently
infuriated the NRA which upped its
lobbying efforts culminating in what was
reported to be a lengthy phone call
between President Trump and the NRA
leader Wayne LaPierre
when the president is speaking to Wayne
LaPierre he knows he's not speaking just
to Wayne LaPierre he's speaking to his
entire membership and the millions of
gun owners that he can mobilize in favor
of the president should he so choose
shortly after the call president Trump
returned to the NRA playbook repeating
what has been the organization's mantra
the gun doesn't pull the trigger a
person does and we have great mental
illness and following yet another
shooting in a desert exis a few days
later the president was disparaging
about the background checks he'd
advocated a matter of weeks before 4:00
or 5:00 going back even five or six or
seven years for the most part as strong
as you make your background checks they
would not have stopped any of it
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says no gun legislation will be
considered unless it is certain
President Trump will approve it that's
important to a lot of my members it also
at the risk of repeating a history
lesson is the only way we will get along
the question unanswered given its
relationship with President Trump will
the NRA need to approve any legislation
to Mike Hanna al Jazeera Washington